y la cadera consta de dos partes
principales que se ensamblan como una
articulación la cabeza femoral en la
parte superior de la pierna y el
acetábulo en la pelvis
un reemplazo total de cadera se realiza
generalmente cuando el daño grave de la
artritis o una lesión dificulta la
realización de las actividades diarias
durante el procedimiento la cabeza
femoral y el acetábulo se reemplazan por
componentes artificiales denominados
prótesis una prótesis de cadera
artificial consiste en una copa
denominada componente acetabular y un
pie de metal denominado componente
femoral
antes de someterse al procedimiento se
le administrarán fluidos intravenosos
antibióticos y medicamentos para
ayudarlo a relajarse se le colocará un
catéter en la vejiga para drenar la
orina la mayoría de los reemplazos de
cadera se realizan con anestesia general
en cuyo caso se insertará un tubo
respiratorio en la garganta para
ayudarlo a respirar durante la operación
debido a que la pérdida de sangre y
líquidos puede ser significativa se
preparará sangre del banco de sangre en
caso de que necesite una transfusión
usted puede tener la oportunidad de
reunir y almacenar su propia sangre al
prepararse para la cirugía el cirujano
comenzará realizando una incisión sobre
la articulación de la cadera
separando los músculos y ligamentos para
exponer la cápsula articular
después de realizar la incisión en la
cápsula el cirujano dislocara la cabeza
femoral del acetábulo
extirpar a cualquier hueso o cartílago
dañado en el acetábulo dará una nueva
forma a la cavidad acetabular y
asegurará la prótesis acetabular en el
lugar utilizando cemento especial o
tornillos pasando luego al fémur el
cirujano extirpar a la cabeza femoral
dará forma al fémur restante para que se
adapte al vástago protésico y asegurara
el componente femoral utilizando cemento
u otras técnicas una vez que ambos
componentes se encuentren firmemente en
el lugar
el cirujano desplazará la cabeza femoral
protésica en su equivalente acetabular
probará el movimiento de la nueva
articulación de la cadera y verificará
que esté colocada correctamente por
medio de una radiografía luego el
cirujano cerrará la cápsula articular
preparará los músculos colocará un
drenaje en la cadera para extraer el
exceso de fluidos y cerrará la incisión
con puntos o grapas al finalizar la
operación se le colocará temporalmente
un dispositivo especial para evitar la
dislocación de la cadera usted será
trasladado al área de recuperación
posquirúrgica hasta que esté estable y
se despierte de la anestesia de ser
necesario puede recibir una transfusión
de sangre en este momento usted
continuará con los fluidos intravenosos
y los antibióticos durante un período
corto y se le administrarán medicamentos
para el dolor si fuera necesario es
posible que se les retire el catéter
después de varios días para evitar la
formación de coágulos sanguíneos en la
pierna se le administrará un diluyente
de sangre se le solicitará que utilice
medias de compresión neumática y se le
recomendará que comience a caminar lo
antes posible una enfermera o un
terapeuta físico lo ayudará a levantarse
de la cama y utilizar su nueva cadera la
mayoría de los pacientes son dados de
alta del hospital una vez que pueden
caminar con la ayuda de muletas o un
caminador